many of elden rings bosses serve
america's golden order in some shape or
form whether they're loyal to it or
enslaved by it so let's discuss all of
these bosses
starting at a time before order had even
come to the lands between
to the north are mountaintops of the
giants a name that makes it abundantly
clear just who dominated this region of
the world
however it was not always this way
according to the borealis missed
incantation the ice dragons were once
lords of the mountaintops long ago until
they were defeated by the fire giants
and chased from the peak
and perched upon this peak stands an
enormous forge interestingly the chain
rings of this forge depict dragons which
might be a reference to the dragons that
once dwelt here and while i don't think
we can say for sure who built this forge
the art of smithing is said to have
originated among the giants and the
craft was even once considered divine so
it seems likely that at the very least
they made good use of this fire
sparks from this forge would fall down
and fertilize the smoldering flowers
that bloomed upon the mountaintops and
it seems like it was a pretty crucial
part of life in this region
the most ancient giants here were called
fire giants and according to the burn of
flame incantation they have long held a
solitary curse to serve as keepers of
the flame for eternity now traditionally
in from software games curses are the
domain of the gods and indeed the fire
giants are cited to have borrowed power
from one such god who is represented
here by a single large red eye
this god is called a god of the flame
and it's believed to be able to inhabit
fire itself as well as the bodies of the
fire giants who worshipped it
the giants shared borders with the
astrologers who according to their
legendary sword of knight and flame
established themselves in the
mountaintops and considered the fire
giants their neighbors the relationship
here is implied to be friendly even
collaborative maybe as the sword does
combine the power of both flame
and the power of the primeval current
that's glimpsed within the night sky
the sword would go on to become a
treasure of the carrion royal family and
the carrions themselves are likely
descendants of the astrologers
generations later these carrion royals
would call upon their old giant allies
for aid but we'll get to that in a
moment
the fire giants also had another
neighbor with whom relations were not so
amicable further down the mountains just
past the forbidden lands roamed the
knights of zamor
according to their armor these
long-lived warriors clad in biting
freezing winds are said to have been the
mortal enemies of the fire giants since
time immemorial according to their
weaponry these beings were devoted to
winter itself and had weapons styled
after icy winds and bodies that were
cloaked in swirling ice storms it makes
good sense that such cold beings would
be natural mortal enemies of the fire
giants and they commonly did challenge
their larger rivals but it seems like
their true chance came when queen
america waged war against the fire
giants and the knights of zamor gladly
joined her offensive they earned great
renown amongst the order of the odd tree
and many ancient heroes of zamor became
hailed as heroes as the fire giants were
largely wiped from the face of the earth
after this war
now up until now i've resisted calling
the giants evil but the reality is that
in pretty much every item description
their god is described as a fel god and
the giant's flame is a flame of ruin and
to be fair their god doesn't seem like a
super nice guy i mean it only really
opens its eye when the fire giant boss
sacrifices a leg which is pretty metal
but i'm sort of giving them the benefit
of the doubt because i think it's pretty
clear who's writing the history about
this fel god here
the many mentions of this god as evil
clearly come about because
fire itself was just this extremely
taboo topic during america's age of the
earth tree and it's not just giants
flame items that mention this fire in
general was prohibited to those who
served the earth tree which was a pretty
smart defensive measure especially
considering that many rival outer gods
also have a flame of their own the
formless mother has blood flame the
three fingers have frenzied flame the
outer god of death has ghost flame but
giant's flame in particular was capable
of burning the earth tree and that is a
fact that clearly inspired the
inevitable war with the giants
so the giants were deemed mortal enemies
of the earth tree and they allegedly
desolated nature triggered avalanches
and whipped up storms of flame with
their roars clearly those who served the
ode tree were afraid and perhaps
rightfully so
and so led by lord godfrey the forces of
the earth tree went to war the fire
giants borrowed from the power of the
fel god to fight against the earth tree
but were defeated nonetheless according
to the burn of flame incantation this
released the fire giants from their
curse to serve as keepers of the flame
all except one who the fel god still
hides within and upon realizing that the
giant's flame would never die america
left this last giant alive knowing it
was bound to protect the flame for all
eternity and thus leaving it cursed
cursed to protect the flame from someone
like us
in addition to the knights of zamor many
lesser giants were also roped into the
war
against the fire giants these lesser
giants are called trolls and are
confirmed to be a race that is descended
from the giants this relationship is
clearer at the mountaintops where the
trolls here still cast giants flame
incantations troll hammers were even
once used as ancient ceremonial smithing
tools thus it seems evident that the
trolls and the fire giants coexisted for
a time and then fell further and further
apart
because while some trolls are assumedly
still fire giants at heart
many now are not in fact at the heart of
most trolls is
nothing there's this suspicious hollow
here almost as if something has been
ripped out of their torso and when you
consider what's upon the torso of the
last remaining fire giant the truth
becomes pretty clear right every single
troll is now missing that giant eye of
their outer god
and if you manage to look really closely
here at a troll we realize that in its
place is this strange stone tablet that
is held in place by what look like roots
as pointed out by quailag these rooted
tablets are very reminiscent of the
rooted shackles that were created to
bind the omen twins moog and morgot
which might suggest that the trolls are
also being shackled or suppressed by
america in some way
this is just speculation of course but
america does have this suspicious set of
stone tablets in her chambers and i
think it's a good theory for sure
a sword gravestone in the mountaintops
elaborates further on the troll's role
in the war of the giants here champions
battled and allegedly the trolls
betrayed but what was the nature of this
betrayal did these lesser giants resent
their larger kin or did marrica force
this betrayal in some way with the stone
shackles i think that's largely up to
you guys but whatever the case
nowadays the trolls are said to have
lost their minds and are inseparable
from the weight of their rusty swords
which have long since lost any trace of
gold so whether they carry coffins or
mine down at the bedrock of the earth
their sad state brings to mind
enslavement now more than anything else
that said some trolls do seem to have a
little bit more dignity and
these are the ones that fought against
the ode tree later on these were the
enchanted troll knights deemed comrades
of the young ranala and they were called
into service when the queen invoked an
oath that they swore long ago as
mentioned earlier the trolls go way back
to when the fire giants and the
astrologers were still neighbors and
back then it seems for whatever reason
they swore an oath to the astrologers
and later when the carrions went to war
against the urgery i assume the trolls
were finally called into that service to
be treated as true knights of carrier
wielding swords embedded with blue
glintstone and summoning enormous glint
blades they fought aminar with their
long-lost human comrades
eg is another such example of that
relationship by the way he became the
carrion family's royal blacksmith and
unlike the stone digger trolls he
actually uses that weapon for its
intended purpose as a blacksmith's
hammer
and now he serves the lady rani who he's
known ever since her childhood
next i want to talk about the night's
cavalry these recurring bosses wander
the dim roads at night and were once led
by the fel omen now this description
specifically references margaret's title
as the fel omen not morgot's title as
the omen king
and i think this is important because
margaret represents this undercover
extension of morgot who scouts further
out in the world and takes out champions
who approach all the way from stormville
castle morgot's big role in the story is
that he's a stout defender of the urgery
who wouldn't dare betray the golden
order he calls all the other demigods
willful traitors all simply for fighting
over the great runes of the elden ring
even radhan who has a lot of signs of
being quite loyal to the golden order is
called a traitor simply because he
fights at one stage another character
who has a great rune you can even see
morgot in one of these opening cutscene
cinematics leaping onto what looks like
radon and managing to even get an attack
off on one of the mightiest of the
demigods actually a channel named
smotown has a really good little video
discussing whether this is indeed redan
and i'd highly recommend you go and
check that out
anyway my point is the knights cavalry
seemed to fulfill a similar role to
margate according to their armor they
were deliverers of death for great
warriors knights and champions
simple as that
no motive is listed except that they
have a reputation for taking out the
greatest warriors of the world and that
makes sense that that would be their aim
because only the strongest can acquire
two great runes and approach the earth
tree so it's almost as if strength
itself must be stifled so that morgot's
failing order might be maintained
as for why margaret defends stormvale i
like to think that he's fighting here
because he recognizes that godric is the
weakest of the demigods who yet remains
so he's bolstering his strength in that
sense and trying to maintain this
unsteady
stalemate having a strong defense is
essentially the guiding principle of
those who serve the erd tree especially
as you get closer to the capital
there are numerous examples of this the
soldiers of lane dell fight their
battles defensively the knights of lane
del always put their shield before the
sword and lanedale itself the city is
built to withstand siege with layers and
layers of defensive measures built in
and the protective standard to which all
defenders of the old tree aspire is that
of the tree sentinels whose order became
the living rampart of the earth tree
embellished with golden tree crested
armor and shields that can retaliate
with bolts of light they turn defense
into offense
and that's the idea in lane dell defense
is the best offense and the way this
idea is presented is just such beautiful
storytelling
so many characters in other areas of the
lands between long to return to the
blessed land of the ode tree and even
for you it's this goal that looms over
you the entire game so the path is
designed to repel everyone getting close
you know the highway through leonia has
fallen apart so you need to take this
secret waterlogged route up through the
mountain this is my favorite part of the
game by the way finding this secret path
through the mountains and infiltrating
the altus plateau
and then when you finally get there
there are countless ballista and golem
arches and they're all positioned facing
outwards and finally you even find a
side entrance to lane dell and that is
even guarded by a tree sentinel and it's
not just any tree sentinel this one is
actually a draconic tree sentinel which
is kind of different
this variant of sentinels arose after
the ancient dragons attacked lane del in
its history and we talked more about
this event in the video about the
demigods but in the end the ancient
dragons were befriended and worship of
the ancient dragons was deemed
acceptable alongside belief in the odory
dragons were conjoined
with the golden order so to speak and
the dragon cultists took after them in a
physical fashion
also instrumental to the rise of the
earth tree were the crucible knights
they were eventually scorned for their
strength for their appearance and for
their close resemblance to chaos and how
that inspired who they originally were
sixteen of these nights served godfrey
the first elden lord and all 16 of them
yet remain across the lands between
one is imprisoned in an ever jail
two appear to be dead and are summoned
to fight you as spirits a number of
crucible knights still patrol lane dell
some protect great tree roots though
most just stand dejected in lost corners
of the earth and one of them has even
found a new blasphemous master so the
next time you fight these think
carefully about where they are and who
they're fighting with because each
knight is a distinct character with
purpose or lack thereof even though they
were all once united by a common purpose
and a single lord
many of these knights fight with
different aspects of the crucible some
fight with wings some with horns fire
and tail but what they all have in
common is their mastery of their lord
godfrey's signature stomp attack which
breaks up the earth beneath their feet
this is such a cool homage to godfrey
you know knowing the law is great it
definitely makes dying to it feel a
little bit better right anyway i think
it's important to remember that godfrey
and his crucible knights existed in an
age before the odd trees an age with the
great tree in its primordial form
back when there was this red tinted
crucible of life and these were warriors
who drew power from its chaos eventually
however they were brought on board with
order which is best exemplified by
godfrey being tamed by the beast regent
upon his back
there are two types of ornamentation
that the crucible knights can have
there's ax ornamentation which is worn
by crucible knight or dovis and his men
and i think the axe is a bit of a homage
to godfrey again and then there are some
nights that have great tree
ornamentation and these are displayed by
the knight seluria and her men which is
of course a reference to the great tree
itself
and i'd like to quickly talk about the
great tree in one of my first lore
videos i proposed that there was a great
tree that must have existed before the
erd tree and that the erd tree might
have even replaced this great tree this
was based on the english root resin item
description which has the word great
tree capitalized and as one word which
certainly makes you think that it's a
distinct tree right the line is the
roots of the great tree once linked to
those of the earth tree which is a line
that seems to clearly set up that these
are two separate trees
except the japanese translation doesn't
say that japanese translation says these
roots are said to have once been
connected to the golden tree it does
mention the great tree earlier but it
seems to just be referencing the ode
tree as that great tree because it is a
really big tree
some people have taken this to mean that
there was no great tree before the earth
tree and
you know while that's certainly possible
i do think it's still fair to argue that
a great tree existed before the oak tree
for one many of the crucible night items
reference a primordial form of the earth
tree and they have ornamentation and
history that is based on this primordial
holiness that is not the holiness of the
odd tree so calling it a great tree
might just be referencing that tree and
secondly siluria defends a giant tree in
the deep root depths it's one that has
this hollowed-out entrance that is
reminiscent of the entrance at the earth
tree as well so maybe there's something
here i just kind of wanted to set that
straight for now
but the reality is that we don't really
know for sure and hopefully dlc will
shed a light on some of these past ages
of the world which seems to be a common
trend with from software dlc
and there just really are so many
remnants of previous ages in this game
and i'd love to see a little bit more
about what their cultures really were
like it kind of makes you resent just
how all-encompassing the odd tree became
so many of these cultures have been lost
and i guess that's how a lot of
characters in game feel as well they
feel upset by that and knowing this fact
helps you understand why so many of
these characters are
okay with burning down the odd tree
they're totally fine with that and this
brings us to our next boss because in
the act of burning down the odd tree you
release a slew of ulcerated tree spirits
from it these spirits lie suffering
beneath the ash until you come along but
of course you fight many of these tree
spirits across the lands between even
before the end game there's an ulcerated
tree spirit at the husk of this minor
herd tree there's a bunch in catacomb
dungeons by great tree roots there's
even one at the husk of the hailik tree
there's a lot of these some might even
say there's too many of these bosses i
think they're the worst boss in elden
ring but anyway
understanding their law might make it a
bit more palatable so while these
creatures fight near the trees i don't
think they're defending them rather i
kind of think they're this corrupted
by-product of dead or dying trees we
know that one of the new purposes of the
earth tree is to accept spirits and
allow them to live on and it's almost
like these ulcerated spirits are this
horrific failure of that process
one of miyazaki's favorite themes in
these games is the idea that life is not
supposed to be eternal and
i think these spirits are a physical
manifestation of stagnation and decay
they're this product of an age of an
urgery that really should have ended a
long time ago most tree spirits drop
golden seeds which are also found at the
base of smaller illusory trees and they
read when the olden ring was shattered
these seeds flew from the odd tree
scattering across the various lands as
if life itself knew that its end had
come
the talisman also goes on to say the ode
tree was once perfect and eternal and
thus it was believed that earth tree
seeds could not exist this was back when
there was an age of plenty when
blessings literally dripped from the
boughs of the ode tree like sap
and the earth tree's warm light healed
those who bathed in its rays theod tree
flourished with abundance yet it was
only for a fleeting moment such is the
course of all life
then the leaves began to fall and as you
know from the introduction and the
endings the fallen leaves tell a story
the story is that the odd tree was
withering
scattered across the lands between are
minor herd trees where you go to collect
crystal tears basins were placed at the
feet of minor herd trees in order to
collect these tears though in some cases
these tears are dropped by earth tree
avatars instead when the elden ring was
shattered the avatars emerged wielding
ceremonial staffs that depict the odd
tree in its historic radiance these
creatures are the will of the dying
earth tree made manifest i think they
are literally part tree after all and
they fight desperately to protect the
minor earth trees which are the
offspring of the withering oak tree
itself some avatars placed in caled and
michela's hailig tree are rotten avatars
and they even have this uniquely
designed staff that festers with rot
just as they do remember the hailik tree
is also an emulation of the ode tree so
it makes sense that it has its own
avatars as well
and they fight on because to many of
these creatures any odd tree whether
it's minor or a copy or doomed is
something worth protecting
so if you've made it all the way to the
end of this video then chances are you
love this kind of long form content so
an audible subscription might also be
just right for you sign up at
audible.com or text vaatividia to 500
500 and you'll get a free credit for the
first month and then again for every
paid month thereafter but this time i'd
recommend you spend that credit on the
sandman which might be just one of the
most unique audiobooks that you've ever
listened to it has its own cast of voice
actors including the author neil gaiman
himself who narrates as well as sound
effects and music it's an incredible
introduction to the story that a lot of
people are talking about right now have
a listen and see what i mean
the year was 1916.
roderick burgess conceived a plan in my
power
he would capture death
did burgess know what he had got don't
you you are death
finally i am free
so if you'd like access to this or to
thousands of other audio books or
podcasts then visit
audible.com varity video or text vanity
video to 500 500 thank you to audible
for sponsoring this video and thank you
for watching